es una cabina sin puerta vale
Se pondrá
y seis siete metros o sea ahí apilaban
todos los cuerpos ya semi anestesiados
con total
además con
un cinismo
naval
no no
Y la verdad que cuando vos miras esa
caja miras ese día
arriba
[Música]
[Aplausos]
porque esto es lo más perverso
arrojando los embolos de la muerte Los y
las desaparecidas
desaparecían totalmente es decir los
militares
los genocidas querían destruir toda
evidencia no querían arriesgarse a que
en un enterramiento o en el fondo de un
lago aparecieran los cuerpos de las
desaparecidos
[Música]
el único lugar que no se ve muy rápido
de la calle ir a la excesma y estar en
capuchita y ahora tener la posibilidad
de ver el avión Realmente es como
movilizante Viste Ese es contradictorio
porque por un lado decís bueno Qué
suerte que podemos hacer todo para
cerrar la historia y por otro lado vas a
estar
viendo el lugar de donde tiraron a
nuestras madres la verdad que es es
fuerte es fuerte
[Música]